Harry: From exclusive
items to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Chinese takeout
in the US and the UK.
This is "Food Wars."
Here are all the menu items you'll find
at a UK Chinese takeaway that
you might not find in the US.
Here's all of the Chinese
takeout we got at our local spot
that you might not be
able to find in the UK.
We'll start with the appetizers.
In the UK, it's pretty common
when you order a Chinese
to order a few starters,
and you kind of eat them
alongside your meal.
One thing to point out,
almost all of these are beige,
and I think that's going
to be a bit of a theme
as we go throughout this episode.
A lot of British Chinese food
is just kind of beige fried
stuff, and we love it.
We'll start with an
exception to the beige rule,
with crispy seaweed.
It's actually got a misleading name,
because this isn't seaweed.
It's shredded cabbage
which is then deep fried.
It's always aggressively salty.
Sometimes you get a little bit
of fish flakes sprinkled on top.
I think this one is
basically just fried cabbage
with some salt powder on it.
When we have a Chinese takeaway at home,
it would pretty much be the
only green thing on our plates.
And here's what we got for
our exclusive appetizers,
starting with the steamed dumplings.
That's so good. I love a dumpling.
Another pretty iconic starter
is a chicken satay skewer.
They will take a piece of
chicken, put it on a skewer,
grill it up in a kind of satay sauce,
which is mostly peanuts,
and they'll serve it to you there.
We also have a bit of
additional satay sauce
for dipping as well. These are great.
They're always a little bit dry.
I think that's why you
have to have the sauce
on the side as well.
Next we have the scallion pancake,
which literally looks like
a cut-up little pancake.
I'm going to take a taste.
Yeah, that's really tasty.
I want to dip this in something, though.
I'm getting the urge to dip.
When I think of a
British Chinese takeaway,
this might be one of the main
dishes that comes to mind.
These are sweet and sour chicken balls.
So, the sweet and sour bit
actually just refers to the sauce
that it's served with.
It's basically just a piece of chicken
which is then battered and deep-fried.
Mm-hmm.
Now, these vary in quality a lot
from restaurant to restaurant.
If chicken balls aren't your thing,
then we also have the
option of a prawn ball.
Now, instead of a piece of chicken,
they take an entire prawn,
batter it, and deep-fry it.
Kind of like a tempura prawn,
but I think a lot heavier on the batter.
We've been locked in a debate here as to
if there's any difference
between prawn and shrimp.
It seems like sometimes
they're used interchangeably,
but maybe they are
actually different species.
I don't know if Nico,
you have any thoughts
on the differences
between prawn and shrimp.
There is actually a difference
between shrimp and prawns.
It's not just linguistic.
Shrimp are more common in the US
and tend to be smaller
with a more savory flavor
when compared to prawns.
Charlie's saying that when
he's had it in the past,
it's been like a sort of prawn paste
mashed up into a ball, whereas these ones
are just whole prawns inside some batter,
so I feel like I've
got a better deal here.
This is a fried wonton.
It's so cute. It looks
like a little flower.
That is so good and crunchy.
Next up, I did want to take
a look at British wontons.
I know you can get these in America,
but I thought there might
be some differences.
So, these ones are not
crispy. These are steamed.
Pretty tasty. Not something
that I would commonly order.
Moving on, we have the crab rangoons.
These are kind of a meme
now for some reason.
I don't know why. These
had a spike in popularity
just in general, but this
is what they look like.
Kind of similar to a wonton, but bigger.
Let's crack this bad boy open.
Oh!
Gorj.
The filling is just crab and cream cheese.
I get it, I think.
I get why it's so popular.
This is a banger.
When you talk about your
beige-food Mount Rushmore,
this has got to be up there.
This is sesame prawn toast.
We have four beige foods
immortalized forever in stone.
Now, if you order a full
English breakfast in the UK,
you're likely to find
some fried bread on there.
Basically, what Chinese
restaurants in the UK have done
is elevate fried bread by putting a layer
of prawn paste in the middle
and then topping it with
loads of sesame seeds.
These are delicious. I love these.
Moving on, we have the spareribs.
I have to admit, I've
never had a sparerib.
It's not something I've ever ordered.
These have bones!
That's literally a bone.
I thought I ordered
the boneless spareribs,
but I guess I ordered the spareribs
with the Peking duck sauce,
and they look and smell amazing,
so I am going to take a bite anyway.
Yeah, that's literally so good.
That is so good! Why don't I order ribs?
That's so yummy.
Now, I was shocked when I saw these
as an exclusive in this episode,
but our next one is prawn crackers.
These are another thing that you'll see
on pretty much every UK
Chinese takeaway order.
Even if you don't order them,
often they'll just throw
you in a bag for free.
They're just great for mopping up
bits of sauce or something.
You can also dip them in
the sweet and sour sauce,
and you kind of get this crackling.
I really almost hope
that we've made a mistake
in the script and that
you can in fact find these
on Chinese takeout menus in the US,
because they're great, and
you guys are missing out.
The last two items we wanted
to talk about were chips.
We have two versions here that you'll find
on pretty much every British
Chinese takeaway menu.
We have regular chips, and we
have salt and pepper chips.
As I'm sure some of you might know,
British people don't tend to have
the most adventurous palates in the world,
and there's usually a
lot of demand for chips.
Same with Indian restaurants
and Chinese restaurants.
Basically, they're just
catering to the demand
of the British public.
Also, it's very common to pair your chips
with curry sauce.
So, curry sauce in this sense,
it probably has some of
the similar flavorings
that you would find in a
katsu-curry-type sauce.
I would refer to this type of curry sauce
as chip-shop curry sauce,
and that kind of applies to
whether it's Chinese takeaways
or fish and chip shops.
Then we also have the
salt and pepper chips.
Now, salt and pepper
seasoning is quite common
at Chinese restaurants in the UK.
That refers to a seasoning mix
which is comprised of salt, white pepper,
and Chinese five spice.
They kind of take that, base it around it,
they'll make chips, cook
them most of the way,
and then finish them usually in a wok
with some chili peppers, some onion,
and some spring onion.
These are delicious.
Now, I will defend salt and pepper chips,
but they were kind of at the center
of that TikTok controversy
around British Chinese food,
which honestly is kind of
why we've made this episode.
I also got an order of fries.
Obviously these are not an exclusive
just to US Chinese takeout places,
but I just wanted to show
what they looked like here
versus in the UK.
Very bland. I don't even
think these have salt on them,
which is kind of interesting.
This is definitely one of those
Chinese takeout menu items
that feels very catered to
a different kind of palate.
I would say that I do not see people
ordering french fries pretty much ever
from a Chinese food place.
Something like this is probably for kids
who are picky eaters,
which I definitely was.
I was ordering white
rice and chicken wings
from Chinese takeout as a child
because I didn't want to
try anything else, but,
that's what this feels like.
Something to please the children.
I'm calling Harry a child right now.
Something to please the child.
Another British Chinese takeout staple
is a crispy aromatic duck pancake.
Now, it sits somewhere kind of between
an appetizer and a main course,
because, I mean, if you
gave me enough of this,
I would just eat that as my main.
It can be kind of
expensive, so I feel like
some people just get
a little bit to share.
So, it was neatly packaged for us,
but it comes in a few
different components.
Obviously, we have the
crispy aromatic duck itself.
These little crispy bits
of skin are amazing.
We have the pancakes.
We have hoisin sauce.
And then you have your vegetables.
In this case, we have
some julienned cucumber
and spring onion.
I'll do a little demo assembly here.
I feel like everyone's got different ways
of assembling, so don't judge mine.
Start with a pancake.
Get as much of that
crispy skin as possible.
Little bits of cuke.
Some spronions.
Hoisin is kind of a plum-based sauce.
Just nice and sweet.
Works really well with the savory.
Have some fun with it, you know?
Beautiful. These are sensational.
I've not actually had
one of these in a while.
Next, let's talk about the
exclusive soup options we have.
This is vegetable bean curd soup.
I should mention that I never order soup
when I get Chinese takeout,
but it's obviously going to
vary from person to person.
Some people like a little soup appetizer.
I'm not one of those people.
Although I love soup in general.
It mostly just smells like broccoli to me.
It doesn't have a super-strong flavor.
I feel like the broth isn't as rich
as I wanted it to be, but
the tofu is really tasty.
Next we have the hot and sour.
I've never had hot and sour soup before,
so I am interested to try it.
This smells a lot like
sweet and sour sauce,
so I assume that that's what's in here.
I'm seeing vegetables,
what I think is tofu.
It smells really good, so
let's take a little slurp.
The texture is not my favorite.
I think it's got the
texture of a sauce to me,
so sipping it like a
soup doesn't feel right.
But it does taste good.
And lastly, we have the egg drop soup,
which I feel like is a pretty popular soup
when you're ordering Chinese takeout here.
The one we got here is
chicken and sweet corn,
which I think is kind
of like the archetypal
Chinese takeaway soup here in the UK.
I won't necessarily go out of my way
to order one of these,
although I do think they're pretty tasty.
One thing to point out though
is the texture of these,
because if you're not used to it,
it can really take you by surprise.
There's something about a
chicken and sweet corn soup
in particular that's just so comforting.
We actually do have a corn
and chicken soup here too,
I just don't think it's as popular
as something like a hot and sour soup.
In the UK, we have a lot
of fried-rice dishes.
These probably could be
ordered as your main meal,
but I would say in the UK,
they're more traditionally
ordered alongside a
meat or a vegetable dish
and kind of enjoyed together.
We picked out a couple of options.
Here is the house-special fried rice,
and then also we have
the Singapore fried rice.
I just wanted to find out what makes this
the house-special fried rice,
because usually, it'll include a variation
of kind of things mixed in with it.
There's little pieces of chicken, pork,
and prawn in here, as well
as some spring onions.
The Singapore fried rice
seems to actually have
the same fillings, because I'm seeing
these little tiny shrimps in them.
I'm seeing bits of
chicken and pork as well.
I think this is supposed to be
a slightly spicier fried rice,
so let me give this one a quick try.
Not overpoweringly hot,
but definitely more of a
chili kick to that one.
Moving on to our fried-rice option,
we only had one, and this is
the young chow fried rice.
It's basically made with a bunch
of different protein options.
Looking down right now,
I just see spareribs,
I see chicken, I see shrimp.
Looks kind of good.
I've never thought of
eating multiple meats
at one time like this.
I would argue and say
that fried rice in general
is a popular food here.
I make it all the time.
It's such an easy dish to make at home.
And it's definitely popular
at Chinese takeout places,
but for some reason, we only
had one exclusive option
at this particular location.
I'm going to try to get a bite
with every single meat on it.
Oh! There it is.
It has a very odd taste when it's
three different meats at
once, but it's not bad.
It's actually pretty good.
Now, chow mein has to be
one of the most popular
dishes in the UK.
I think surveys have actually
placed it as the No. 1 dish.
It's pretty versatile.
I'd say usually, again,
this would be an accompaniment
to maybe a meat dish as well,
or you could kind of
just eat this on its own.
Personally, chicken chow
mein is my favorite,
and I think probably
most Brits' favorite too,
but you can also just get plain,
vegetable, or various other toppings.
Here we have the chicken chow mein.
It's effectively just a
stir-fried-noodle dish.
Chow mein definitely is a thing here,
it just isn't a thing at
this particular restaurant.
I'm sorry I have to repeat myself so much.
Let's talk noodles.
This is the pan-fried noodle,
this is the lo mein,
and this is the Singapore mei fun.
Opening this up, I knew
exactly what it smelled like.
It smells like curry, so there has to be
some sort of curry element in it.
It smells really good, so I
think I'm going to take a bite.
I've never had this before.
And it also looks like they use
a smaller noodle than in
either of these two dishes.
It's like those thin, is it,
like, vermicelli noodles?
Vermicelli noodles.
That's my daughter's name.
[crew laughs]
This dish also has
multiple proteins going on.
I'm seeing chicken, and I'm seeing shrimp.
I don't know if there's
anything else underneath,
but that's what I see right now.
The flavor's pretty good.
I don't know if I like vermicelli noodles.
I think this is my first time having them.
They're just such a thin noodle.
I like something chewier,
like the ones that come in the lo mein.
Once you get past the rice
and the noodle portions,
the Chinese takeaway menus in the UK
are usually categorized by protein,
so you'll choose either chicken, pork,
beef, or anything else,
and then you kind of choose a sauce
that goes with that.
For example, we can get
sweet and sour chicken,
but you can also get sweet and sour pork
and sweet and sour beef.
From each protein category,
we're going to show you
a couple of either interesting
or unique food items.
Let's start with chicken.
Here I have lemon chicken.
This is another one of those
that's probably going to be found
on pretty much every Chinese
takeaway menu in the UK.
The sauce is pretty good, though.
It's lemony. A little bit
sweet. A little bit tart.
Then here we have the kung po chicken.
You might also see this
referred to as kung pao chicken,
with that A in the middle there,
but it's the same dish.
It's basically not too dissimilar
to sweet and sour chicken
that you might find
on the menu at a UK Chinese takeout.
It's these dredged and
fried pieces of chicken
in a sweet and spicy sauce.
Kung pao chicken I think traditionally
also might have some peanut in it.
In the US, it's exactly the same.
Our menus are categorized
by the protein type,
but a lot of the dishes
are really different,
so you don't always get the same sauce
for, say, a seafood dish as
you would a chicken dish.
Let's start with the chop suey,
which I have never had before,
but I'm very interested.
You can get it with any protein.
We got ours with chicken.
And here's what that looks like.
The chicken looks a little pale.
I feel like this is a
surprisingly bland dish
compared to a lot of other chicken dishes
I've had from Chinese takeout.
It's definitely not my favorite.
Moving on to the sesame chicken.
This was a fan favorite.
I was told I had to get this.
I'm not a sesame-chicken orderer,
but my friends and coworkers are.
Yeah, it's so good.
Next we have orange chicken,
which, as the name suggests,
has orange in the sauce.
And this particular place
uses the orange peel
to season the chicken.
I've definitely had a lot
of orange chicken in my day,
particularly the frozen
kind from Trader Joe's.
So it is pretty popular.
It's not a spicy sauce.
It's definitely just a sweet, tangy sauce,
but it's very delicious.
And last but not least, we
have General Tso's chicken,
which is my personal favorite thing
to order from Chinese takeout.
You'll see it on a lot of
Chinese restaurant menus
here in the US, but it's not
exactly authentic Chinese food.
Shocker.
General Tso was a real general
from the Hunan province
who supposedly enjoyed eating a dish
similar to General Tso's chicken,
although this modern American version
would probably be unrecognizable to him.
The dish was actually created in the 1950s
by a chef named Peng Chang-kuei.
When he immigrated to New York in 1973,
he altered his recipe to
cater to the American palate,
which in this case means
he made it sweeter.
Peng Chang-kuei called
it General Tso's chicken
because he and General Tso
are from the same town.
Now we're on to the beef options.
Now, firstly, I have to shout out
what might be my favorite
British Chinese takeaway dish,
which is crispy shredded beef with chili.
One thing I've got to say,
talking a lot about textures
and crispiness here,
what you will often find from
Chinese takeaways in the UK,
they'll actually break a little hole
in the plastic container.
This is probably the first
thing that I'm ordering
when I'm ordering a Chinese takeaway.
What they do is they get
these little slivers of beef,
dredge them usually in
something like corn flour,
fry them up, and then
toss them in this lovely
sweet and spicy chili sauce.
I just love the variation you get.
Like, some of them will
be slightly chewier,
some of them will be crispier.
Flavors are great.
Next up we have some Szechuan beef.
Now, I really enjoyed hearing Tianran
talking about Szechuan flavors ...
Tianran: The Szechuanese-style
cooking with the peppercorn.
... when we were doing
the US vs China series.
Go check that out.
But I think Szechuan food
tends to be pretty spicy,
and they also use Szechuan peppercorns,
which give you this kind of
numbing effect in your mouth.
The beef here also isn't fried.
It's more just like
pieces of braised beef.
I'm kind of intrigued to give this a try,
although I'm worried
about my spice tolerance.
Yeah, that's pretty spicy.
It's very tasty, very flavorful.
And then finally we've got
some beef in black bean sauce.
I'd say this is a pretty
common one as well,
and this is one that you can also get
in different meat varieties,
so you can get this with the chicken,
with the pork, anything else.
Comes with loads of peppers as well.
Some chili in there, onions.
It's a nice, very rich sauce.
That's really good. That with
some rice, beautiful pairing.
We'll often actually get this one.
This is one of my favorites.
I feel like I've said that
about a lot of things.
I think I just order too
much Chinese takeaway.
There's a variety of beef
dishes that you can get
at Chinese food places here in America.
Today, we got the moo shu beef.
So it's got cabbage, some
mushrooms, obviously the beef.
Let's take a taste.
The beef in that is really,
really tender and delicious.
I actually really like this!
Seafood is also a pretty common option
on UK Chinese takeaway menus.
A lot of the options you will find
have similar sauces to some
of the beef or pork options,
but there are also a
few unique ones as well.
Firstly, we have salt and pepper squid.
You might remember the salt
and pepper chips from earlier.
It's basically crispy squid
cooked in that same seasoning.
Sometimes this might be
found under appetizers.
Today, they had it in their main section,
so we're going with that.
I love crispy squid.
The way that they kind of cut it
with this crosshatch pattern,
particularly in Chinese cuisine,
gives it a really nice texture.
It's not that chewy.
It's really flavorful, not super fishy.
Just to illustrate that sometimes
the sauces are the same in
different parts of the menu,
this is the pepper and
black bean sauce again,
but this time with squid.
Then we have a couple of
prawn options as well.
Here we have the king
prawns in oyster sauce.
And king prawns with cashew nuts.
While we have the prawn
here in its un-balled form,
let me get one of those out.
Nico, how does that look?
Is that a prawn or a shrimp?
Or neither?
That prawn kind of looks shrimpy to me.
It certainly does not
look like a king prawn.
That's not the king of the prawns.
In the US, shrimp is
definitely the most popular
seafood option when you
get Chinese takeout.
We have a couple of shrimp options here,
the Szechuan shrimp and a seafood delight,
which has shrimp in it
and I'm guessing other
delightful sea creatures.
That's just shrimp.
Is that what is delightful?
Or do they mean delight is, like,
you get a bunch of veggies with it?
Let's just try the Szechuan shrimp.
It smells as spicy as I
think it's going to be.
This is probably the biggest
shrimp I've seen today.
I swear I've eaten with a fork before.
Oh no, it's tail-on!
It's spicy, not as spicy as
I thought it was going to be,
but I'm sure the more you
eat it, the spicier it gets.
But that sauce is really, really good,
and the shrimp is awesome,
even though it's got tails on it.
Take the tails off.
We also got a shrimp egg roll.
Harry really wanted me to try this,
and I'm glad he mentioned it,
because I've never had a
shrimp egg roll before.
Just pork. That's what I get every time.
Do you see that one little
tiny piece of shrimp?
I feel like it tastes slightly
different than the pork,
not just because the meat is different.
Another item you'll see in
a lot of Chinese restaurants
in the US is egg foo young.
It's an omelet made with vegetables,
a protein, and a stir-fry sauce.
Whoa, baby.
This is a big omelet.
It smells really good.
It doesn't just smell like egg.
It smells like a lot of good stuff.
It needs a lot more salt, actually.
I wonder if you're supposed to add sauce
or something on top.
I think we're actually supposed to add
this gravy to it, so let me add that
and see if it helps with the salt factor.
This feels very UK-core right now,
me pouring this gravy all over food.
Better.
Still not great. I don't
know if I like this.
Yeah, egg foo young is interesting,
but I'm not sure British people
would really be going
in and kind of ordering
just an omelet from a Chinese takeaway.
I'm not sure how well that
would take off over here.
It's time for s-s-s-s-s-s-sauce talk.
Sauce talk.
If there was ever a time
to do sauce talk, it's now.
So, in front of me here,
I have all the sauces
that were on offer at the
restaurant we ordered from.
I'm going to go through them now,
explain what they are, what
they might be paired with,
and give them a try.
We'll start with a slightly infamous one.
It's British curry sauce.
The British went round the world,
took spices from everybody,
and this is somehow the only
thing that we came up with.
Brits love curry sauce,
or at least this iteration of curry sauce.
There's definitely some
heat there. Not a lot.
It's quite a gentle spice flavor.
There's something about the texture of it.
It's just really satisfying.
That really gloopy, cornstarch-y texture.
Goes excellently with chicken balls.
You'll often see Brits
drizzling this onto chips.
Chips and curry sauce is
a big thing in the UK.
Or you'll just see it drizzled
across your entire succulent Chinese meal.
I will say Joe really loved that
when we did our fish-and-chip-shop
"Food Tours" episode.
It's not just the Brits who can enjoy it.
Then we have another iconic
UK Chinese takeout sauce,
which is sweet and sour.
Depending on where you get it from,
the color again will vary.
That's a pretty well-balanced one.
The first thing that hits
your tongue is the sour,
then it pretty quickly mellows out,
and you get a nice sweet aftertaste.
Again, I think this is kind of intended
to be paired with the chicken balls
or prawn balls or
something else like that.
But I do think a lot of Brits
will just kind of coat
their entire meal in it.
While we're on the subject
of these iconic sauces,
I also have to shout out
the polystyrene cups.
I think Americans might
call that Styrofoam.
But these are really iconic.
This is the standard delivery
vessel for your sauces.
The restaurant that we ordered from
had two chili options.
Firstly, we have sweet chili.
Brits love sweet chili.
This is on the menu at
a lot of restaurants.
And then the next one
that we have is chili oil.
I'd say this one isn't
super-commonly found
on UK Chinese takeout menus.
Next up we have the black bean sauce.
Now, this is the same sauce
that you might have seen in
some of the dishes earlier.
Then we've got two more sauces.
First up, we have hoisin sauce.
Now, this is most commonly
paired with the crispy duck
that you'll find on UK
Chinese takeout menus.
It's a very thick dark brown sauce.
Again, gloopy sauces. We love it.
I think the main
ingredient in hoisin sauce,
or one of the main ingredients, is plum.
So you get this real sweetness from it,
which works very well
with the savory duck meat
and other things on the menu.
And then finally we have barbecue sauce.
Now, I was a little bit confused
when I saw this on the menu,
because barbecue sauce in
the kind of Western sense,
so like a Texas barbecue
sauce, for example,
does not look like this, and I think
that's what I was expecting.
But I think what's
actually being delivered
is more of a Chinese-style barbecue sauce.
What this one makes me think of is more
when you eat, like, a char
siu pork bun, for example.
Because while it is barbecuey,
it's still got some sweetness to it.
There's Chinese five spice in here.
But if you're expecting,
like, Heinz barbecue sauce,
that's not it.
I think out of all of these ones,
the one I would reach for the most
would be the sweet and sour sauce.
It's because I'll almost always order
the chicken balls when I'm making
a Chinese takeout order in the UK,
and one of these will come with it.
Yeah, I think in the UK,
it's kind of just the definitive sauce,
closely followed by curry.
I think that's one of
the biggest differences
between Chinese takeout
in the US and the UK.
Our takeout comes with the
sauce already incorporated,
for the most part.
You do get a mix, though,
of tiny little sauce packets like this.
So, we've got soy sauce,
duck sauce, which is so good.
It's kind of just a sweet sauce.
We have mustard usually,
which I'm not seeing here.
But you do get mustard.
And hot sauce.
I'm pretty sure there are more,
but that's just what we have right now.
And then we have a couple little cups of,
this looks like a paste.
I think that this is a
little tiny container
of oyster sauce, and this
is just a little container
of extra soy sauce, probably for dipping.
If you do not have a drawer
full of these sauces,
I don't know what you're doing.
I feel like everybody has
that drawer in their house
that's filled with random
sauce packets like this.
Now that we've covered
every item individually,
what I wanted to do was
show you my ideal plate
of British Chinese takeaway food.
You might have seen these
on TikTok or elsewhere,
as these kind of broke
the internet a while ago,
but I'm going to show you my version.
I need some chow mein.
The amount of carbs that
might end up on this plate
could be alarming to some,
because we're going to go noodles.
We're also going to go rice.
You know we're going to get
the salt and pepper chips involved.
Then I want a healthy portion
of my crispy chili beef.
I'm going to want some seaweed on here.
Some of this prawn toast.
Definitely a couple of spring rolls.
And of course our prawn crackers as well.
So generally speaking, this
is a pretty normal plate
of Chinese takeaway food
for a British person.
But we're not done there.
The final step, of course,
is to add our sauces.
Yes, that's sauces plural,
because we're going to be
adding both the curry sauce
and the sweet and sour sauce to this.
And honestly, I'm not discriminating here.
This is going pretty
much on the entire meal.
And of course our sweet and sour sauce.
Love it or hate it, that
is your typical plate
of British Chinese takeaway food.
I think I've done a pretty good job there.
British people, please feel
to agree or disagree with me
in the comments below.
Nico, I've got to hear
your thoughts about this.
Would you eat this?
Let me stop you right there.
Why do you guys sauce the whole plate?
Like, doesn't the whole plate just then
taste like that sauce?
You want everything to taste
exactly like that sauce?
Bone app the teeth.
Now let's make up an American plate
of Chinese takeout with
a bunch of staple foods
that I think are pretty
nationally beloved, I would say.
Let's start with our sides,
our little appetizers.
So, we'd probably throw a
couple of wontons on there.
I'd also do some type of roll.
I would usually do an egg roll,
but all we've got left are spring rolls.
Next, you'd have your rice.
I prefer white rice.
I just think it's really easy to pair
with any sort of entrée.
OK, I wouldn't normally eat
the full container of rice,
but we're going to keep it on the plate.
We've got to get some chicken.
You definitely need a side of veg,
so we're going to do broccoli,
because I feel like that's literally
at every single Chinese restaurant,
they have broccoli on the side.
If you ignore the huge
mountain of white rice,
I think this looks pretty appetizing.
The last thing I would add to this plate
is probably some lo
mein, so let's do that.
I didn't mention these before,
but these little fried,
I think they're fried noodle pieces.
They come with soups,
so you can just throw them in your soup.
Have them with your soup.
They're just good to snack on.
I think this looks like a
pretty appetizing plate.
This is probably the point
where folks in the UK
would douse their plate in sauce.
I would do things a little differently.
I really like dipping egg rolls
into the duck sauce, which is this one.
It's so good.
And some people put sauce, I think,
over their rice and stuff.
So we have our white rice, our wontons,
our fried noodles, some spring rolls,
a side of broccoli, sesame chicken,
and the lo mein, which I
think, this kind of sums up
what a typical order
from a Chinese food place
would look like here in America.
If it doesn't look like what
you would order, sorry, babe.
I don't know what to tell you.
This is just what I think.
I can't even believe I
didn't mention it yet.
You have to get a can of Coke on the side.
Any soft drink really will do.
I just think you need a can of soda
with your Chinese takeout.
It's just, it's a sensation like no other.
It goes together.
In the UK when we order
food to be delivered,
we say we're ordering "a takeaway"
rather than ordering "takeout."
Also in the UK, we tend not to bother
adding with the words "food" or "takeaway"
to the type of food we're eating.
For example, if we're
ordering Chinese takeout,
most Brits will just say that
we're having "a Chinese."
Same applies for maybe Indian food,
when you have "an Indian,"
or even a full English breakfast.
In the US we call it "takeout."
They obviously both mean the same thing,
but that's just our
preferred way of saying it.
We also say "Chinese
food" or "Chinese takeout"
rather than just "a Chinese."
We also wanted to look at how each country
packages its food.
In the UK, you might
find your Chinese food
in one of these foiled
boxes with a paper lid.
The other most common form of packaging
is one of these clear plastic tubs.
And then finally for
your appetizer options,
such as some spring rolls,
which we've got here,
they generally will just
come in a paper bag.
I've always seen those
folded cardboard boxes
in American TV shows, and
they do look pretty cool,
I have to say.
Also the cute little takeout boxes
are something that I
feel like we see a lot
maybe in media when someone
orders Chinese food,
but they're not super, super common.
Mostly the food comes in
these kinds of containers,
which is like a black
Tupperware with a clear top.
These are usually reserved for the rice,
maybe the lo mein, but it's not reserved
for all of the food options.
These boxes were actually
inspired by Japanese origami.
Frederick Weeks Wilcox
was the first person
to introduce the paper pail
box in the 19th century,
to carry raw oysters.
He created a patent for it
and called it a "paper pail,"
which it basically is. It's
like a cute little pail.
In the UK and the US, portion sizes
and menu items will vary slightly
depending on the different
restaurants that you go to.
But we did want to compare a
couple of standard menu items
in the US and the UK
to see who might be
getting bigger portions.
One iconic appetizer from a
Chinese takeaway in the UK
is the spring roll.
The restaurant that we ordered from
serves these in a portion size of six.
In the US, spring rolls are
made a little bit differently.
They're made with rice paper,
and they have thinly sliced
vegetables on the inside.
This particular Chinese
restaurant only gave us two,
but I have ordered from some
places that give you more.
It just depends on where you order from.
We do have egg rolls, which
are kind of similar to the UK.
These come in only one
size, as far as I know,
but depending on what
place you order from,
they could be a little bit bigger,
a little bit smaller than this.
My local place, they're actually
a little bit bigger than this size.
In the UK, our egg fried
rice only came in one size.
I don't want to weigh
this outside of the box,
so I'm just going to weigh it in the box.
This is a mountain.
All of this rice just came out
of this tiny little container.
So, this is what our
fried rice looks like.
At this particular restaurant,
they only had one size of this fried rice,
but I have seen places
do small and large sizes.
All right, let's weigh
this mountain of rice.
Harry: It's, like, just
maxed out the scales.
Nico: That's a lot of rice.
We do have chicken included in that.
Just letting you know.
And we did weigh the plate beforehand,
so that's not part of this weight.
The restaurant that we
ordered from had chow mein
in two different sizes, regular and large,
although the large was only available
with certain varieties.
So this is a chicken
chow mein regular size,
and this is their house-special
chow mein in a large size.
We do have chow mein here in America,
but we didn't have it at
this particular restaurant.
We do have pan-fried noodles,
which I think are similar-ish,
so we're going to weigh these.
Harry: Although I feel
like it might once again
be slightly too heavy for the scales.
Moving on to sweet and sour chicken.
That is a tried and true
classic with takeout.
I think that I'm supposed
to sauce it myself,
which isn't the norm for me.
In my experience getting Chinese takeout,
everything is already sauced.
You don't need to add anything.
This time, they came without sauce,
so we're just going to add it ourselves.
In the UK, our sweet and sour
chicken came in one size.
In the UK, this consists of
little fried pieces of chicken,
peppers, onions, and also pineapple.
I'm getting worried that I think
I was supposed to dip
the individual pieces
into sauce and eat it like that.
I've never ordered this.
I just know it's a
common takeout item here.
But I already poured
the sauce all over it,
so let's just weigh it
and see how much it is.
As we mentioned before,
each Chinese restaurant
is unique as to how they
prepare and cook their food,
so it's kind of impossible to know
exactly what's going into each dish.
One ingredient that we did
want to highlight, however,
as it's commonly associated
with Chinese food,
is MSG, or monosodium glutamate.
In 1907, a Japanese
chemist named Kikunae Ikeda
discovered a substance called glutamate,
also known as umami.
He later broke that
substance down into MSG.
MSG is a seasoning and food enhancer
that gives a rich, savory flavor.
MSG is actually very
commonly found in fast foods
including Chick-fil-A, snack
foods including Doritos,
and naturally occurs in some cheeses.
MSG has been recognized as
safe by the FDA several times,
and only contains a third
of the sodium content
of table salt. So why's
it got such a bad rap?
In 1968, The New England
Journal of Medicine
published a letter titled
"Chinese Restaurant Syndrome."
In it, a doctor describes his experiences
after eating at Chinese restaurants,
citing symptoms like "numbness
in the back of the neck,"
"general weakness," and "palpitations."
The blame was placed on MSG,
and the Chinese-restaurant-syndrome
myth quickly spread.
The phrase even ended up in
the Merriam-Webster dictionary.
Despite there being no evidence
that MSG was dangerous,
there was still a public panic around it.
Chinese restaurants in
particular were deemed unhealthy.
Thankfully, the use of MSG is
much more normalized today,
although the xenophobic
misinformation from the 1960s
does still linger.
If you Google "MSG," some of
the suggested search terms
include things like, "Why
are Americans afraid of MSG?"
and, "Is MSG a neurotoxin?"
Short answer, no, it's not.
The first Chinese restaurants
to appear in the UK
were called eating houses.
They would serve Chinese sailors
who would dock in British ports.
This goes as far back as the 19th century
when Hong Kong was part
of the British empire.
Notable locations for
this included Limehouse,
which is part of the East End of London
and was actually where the
original Chinatown was.
The East End of London
was particularly hit
by bombing raids in the Second World War,
which caused Chinatown
to relocate to Soho,
where it is today.
The first recorded Cantonese
restaurant in London
was a place called Cathay,
and it was opened in 1908.
It was opened by a former ship's chef,
a guy called Chung Koon.
It was Chung Koon's son
who opened a restaurant
in Bayswater decades later,
which might have been the kind of origin
of the Chinese takeaway in London.
Apparently, the food was so popular
that if customers couldn't get a table,
they would simply ask for the food to go.
Chung Koon's restaurant, Maxim,
had a very popular dish consisting of pork
and a sweet and sour sauce called jar jow.
While the origins of the dish
are specifically Cantonese,
it just became known as
Chinese food to Britons.
The first known Chinese
restaurant in the US
was called Canton and opened
in 1849 in San Francisco.
The 1850s saw the appeal of the Gold Rush,
so to escape worse conditions in China,
there was a flood of Chinese
immigrants in this time.
Restaurants began popping
up to feed Chinese workers
who missed their cuisine from home,
modifying their favorite dishes
using ingredients that
they could find in the US.
In 1882, the Chinese Exclusion Act
forbade Chinese immigrants
from coming to America.
An exception was made for restaurateurs,
who could apply for merchant visas,
which saw a boom in Chinese restaurants
opening up in the 1910s.
Any new restaurants that opened
had to be considered "high-grade"
to be within the 1882 act,
so the owners lavishly
decorated the restaurants,
and by 1943, the act was revoked.
During this period,
dishes such as chop suey
and egg foo young were
popularized across the country,
especially the spread of chop suey houses.
Chop suey was made from food scraps.
Its name basically means leftovers.
Male migrants who came over from China
had little to no kitchen skills,
and ingredients were different
from those back home,
so they threw together
what they could find,
creating a dish that
was very easy to make.
Chop suey was a popular
Chinese American dish
up until the 1960s, after
which General Tso's chicken
kind of became the new popular thing.
Also during this time,
Chinese food began to be
preserved in cans for
pickling and freezing
because the Great
Depression meant that people
were looking for food
that was more affordable.
Popularizing the chop suey
houses was a turning point
for integrating Chinese
cuisine into American culture,
even if the dish was
eventually less popular.
Chinese food increased
in popularity in the UK
during and after World War II.
Recipes for Chinese cakes
as well as other simple
Chinese recipes were
introduced to Brits by the BBC,
and as some Brits returned
from being stationed
in the Far East, they
brought back with them
a taste for Chinese cuisine.
An influx of Cantonese immigrants
arriving from Hong Kong in the 1950s
brought with it a wave of
Chinese restaurants to the UK.
These restaurants really
blew up in popularity.
The restaurants grew so popular, in fact,
that Billy Butlin introduced
chop suey and chips
to the restaurant menus
at his holiday camps.
One trend that you also saw
was Chinese families taking over
old fish and chip restaurants.
This is why you still see things
like fish and chips or
battered sausage and chips
on the menu at some Chinese restaurants.
Around 1960, The Mandarin
opened in San Francisco,
introducing Americans to
Chinese food beyond chop suey,
like hot and sour soup and pot stickers.
Cecilia Chiang, the
owner of the restaurant,
wasn't sure what food
customers would want,
so she added over 300 items to the menu.
President Nixon's trip to China in 1972
began to normalize relations
between the countries,
and Americans were influenced
to try more Chinese food.
In 1989, the National
Restaurant Association
concluded that Chinese food was actually
the most frequently consumed
cuisine across the country,
and over the next few decades,
the number of Chinese restaurants
went up by the thousands.
In 2007, there were over 43,000.
In the US today, there are over
23,000 Chinese restaurants.
In the 1950s, there were
only 36 Chinese restaurants
in the UK, but the next few decades
saw that number rapidly ascend.
By the late 1990s, that number
had risen to over 5,000.
Today, there are a little over 7,000
Chinese restaurants up and down the UK.
According to a survey, Chinese food
is the second-most-popular
cuisine in the US,
right behind pizza, as of June 2023.
A 2001 poll said that Chinese food
was British people's
favorite foreign cuisine.
This was backed up by
another poll 20 years later,
which said that 25% of Brits
will still opt for Chinese
as their favorite foreign cuisine.
That's really good. I love duck.
I think there's a direct correlation
between how cute an animal
is and how good it tastes.
Because ducks are pretty adorable,
and damn are they tasty.